et puis l'actualité à l'étranger marquée
par la suite du voyage de lionel jospin
en chine premier ministre français est
aujourd'hui à et faille où il a
rencontré le président yang éminent
tournée dans les zones touchées par les
inondations
quant à la journée d'hier elle s'est
terminée par un concert de rock donné à
pékin par une pop star de la chine sur
place le reportage de roland sicard et
bernard connard soirée où fut maroc ont
fait ce pape est en chine l'europe a
longtemps senti le soufre les chansons
de tso etienne une vedette dans son pays
où vivent été interdite
mais tout cela la fable courage et
biennalisation
mais ce matin retour aux choses
sérieuses lionel jospin devait partir en
voyage
le président de la république chinoise
lang et mines ne pouvait pas le recevoir
à pékin il est en province en tournée
d'inspection
après les inondations qui ont ravagé la
chine pour certains rendez vous déplacez
qui équivaut en fait à une sanction
contre la france
elle agace que les chinois a trop
souvent parlé de droite pourtant les
droits de l'homme menait le jeu sports
on a reparlé ce matin au leader chinois
je lui ai dit qu'il me semblait que le
développement économique social éducatif
de la chine ferait que cette volonté
d'affirmation des libertés et des droits
de l'homme deviendrait plus grande
même si j'étais conscient que ce serait
un processus continu lionel jospin qui a
donc voulu montrer que l'on pouvait
parler des droits de l'homme et que les
chinois savait écouter
l'objectif est simple ne pas laisser
peser cette question sur son voyage un
voyage que le premier ministre veut
décontractée